trong tiền bố chính thức về nha xuyên là kham định đứng này bác bỏ lên án và tổ cao trước cơm cốc tế
hành động quân sự cực kìng em trọng giống ý tật hiện.
Y mô xung tôi yêu cầu tốn trọng các tiền trước tế của phần nha xuyên là chúng tôi lên án lại mẹ hình lượng xâm lược
nhằm vào đến lất xin tôi, hành động đã có lý sinh mạng của các quân nhanh của lông thời gian đã cứ đi mạng xứng
thì hưởng zân vô tôi trải như điểm khương nào.
Đại thế là bài chặt từ vào hình.
Chúng tôi sẽ khi ngoả trình tỏng bộ không giàn để li của đến lất.
Với sự kết học chả trẻ dưới lượng của lộ kể sát và nhân dân.
Chúng tôi đã diện 2 trên quy mô lớn tất cả các hệ thống vú trang trên mạng lất trên không
hãy quân trên xong và hẹt tổng tinh lời cho nhẹ vụ phòng thuộc.
Cá đã tắt sạnh bảo, cuộc tân không không chỉ đây sọng hà bình vào tính quốc tế
mà còn đặt khu vực mi là tính và cà đi bê trước vi cơ bất ổn nghiêm chọng.
Đúng thời đi a giỏi chức tiếp tính mạng của hàng trị vui dân.
Với đe zưa ra cho rằng một kêu thực sự của cuộc tân không là chiếm đoạn các ngồi tàn biên chiến lực
đặc biệt là dơ mỏ và pháng sản.
Nhằm phà bớt nên được lập chính trị của cuộc sản này.
Chính phục đe zưa ra nhấn mạng sau hơn 2,5 giành được lập.
Người dân và chính quyền hợp pháp của nước này sẽ tiếp tục kiên định bảo vệ chủ phíanh
và quyền tục viết.
Đúng thời kham định, mọi nước lực, áp đặt, thay đổi chế độ, bằng bú lực, đều sẽ thất bại.